Nick what'd you do that for  do what you killed the mozzie yeah dude  that thing probably has a family you  know  where you going I'm burying it hey 10  can you do me a huge favor and cover my  Sunday shift  I've just got a thing on oh it's kind of  my friend's wedding  it would just would mean a whole lot to  me it'd be a huge favor I know you want  okay sure Oh awesome you are the best  thanks no worries hey Nick what are you  doing  I got a date tonight I'm gonna try  something new of my hair how's the  looking so far it was great yeah sweet  thanks man  hey Jemima happy birthday tan it with my  birthday last week  you didn't get me anything I I could do  this oh yeah okay there you go  cool and surprise ah hey Eli nice shirt  what's that supposed to mean no I'm  being serious I actually like your shirt  what's wrong with the world today  okay so this is Lane as Alan max there  Rob and um they leave ah  it's a lie Oh Eli sorry Matt no one  understands I do it's gonna be okay